[Music]
afternoon everyone and welcome to best
practices for GCE enterprise deployments
thank you all so much for coming I know
we're in the homestretch of next I so
really appreciate that you all could be
here my name is Surrey I am a product
manager on the compute engine team and
the goal for the next 15 minutes is
going to be for me to share with you all
some of the best practices and learnings
that we've picked up over the years and
working with both internally at Google
and with our customers to deploy truly
large deployments of GCE and so we're
gonna have two data sources as part of
sharing that information with you today
we have two data sources so the first
one is the learnings that we picked up
that I just talked about and the second
one second one is going to be I want to
share with you some of the really
exciting feature announcements that
we've made here at next as well as
leading up to next so you have the
latest and greatest product details to
take with you as you go and scale out
your GCE deployments so the first thing
I want to talk about is when we talk
about an effective GCE enterprise
deployment what is our North Star like
what is the goal that we're going
towards and so one part of the goal is
for sure agility almost every customer I
talk to you they want to get to the
cloud to move quickly they want to use
the scale and the power of the cloud to
quickly reach their business goals and
to compete in the space that they're in
but the problem here is agility can't be
our only focus because if you if you're
just moving fast you might be heading
straight towards a cliff and not know it
and so the North Star I want to
introduce here for this talk the goal
that we want to reach towards is agility
with the right guardrails so for example
you want to know that you're moving
quickly but you're doing so in a
cost-effective way and also in a way
that satisfies your legal and regulatory
and compliance requirements right so
you're going to want to mix the the both
of those and this talk is gonna be it's
going to be about how you move fast but
it's also going to be about how you use
the tools that we offer you in GCE and
more broadly and GCP to achieve the
right guardrails as well so
first thing I'll do is I'll look inside
our toolbox and talk a little bit about
the tools that you have available NGC II
to do these sorts of things with kind of
a focus on the new features that we
launched here at next because this is a
300 level talk I'm going to assume some
prior knowledge so we're gonna focus on
some of the newer and exciting things
the first section is going to be up
about choosing the right VM types so
this is going to be key and making sure
that your workloads run quickly and
effectively on GCE and also in a
cost-efficient way so the first thing
I'm going to talk about is the different
machine types that we offer and there
have been some exciting new
announcements in this space so ever
since GC has been launched we've had the
general-purpose machine type so this is
the machine type that you use kind of by
default and we find that it has the best
price performance ratios in general and
that it's well-suited for a lot of
different workloads so you should always
start here when assessing your workloads
and we've seen them effectively used for
all sorts of different workloads
including web serving databases mobile
gaming you name it so you start here but
once but we had this for a long time and
we heard a lot of customers say well I
have maybe a very large in-memory
database that needs to store a ton of
data in that VM for say online
analytical processing and so at a
previous next we announced the memory
optimized machine types
so these upon in the initial
announcement these movie M supported up
to four terabytes of memory but in the
time since then we've heard from a lot
of customers that well you know my
database is constantly growing as the
data that I work with expands and so we
want to make sure that we have the VM
shapes to keep up with that and so here
at this event we announced that we will
have memory optimized machines we're
extending that line to have up to 12
terabytes of memory and that's coming
soon another type of workload that we
hear from customers all about is they
have workloads that are very compute
performance intensive and so in response
to that we released or we're announcing
here the compute optimized line of
machine shapes so why would you want
this particular type of machines we have
customers that have really that are
really sensitive to real-time
performance so for example if you're
running a triple-a gaming server every
millisecond counts and you want to make
sure you have the fastest per core
formitz another reason you'd want this
is we see some customers they have
licensing agreements where they license
perk or and so they want to squeeze the
most juice out of each core as possible
so those are two reasons to look into
the compute optimized machine type this
is now in alpha so if one of those cases
sounds like it'd be useful for your
workloads I encourage you to check out
the blog post that we have on this and
you'll have a sign-up link for the alpha
that's all I'll go into four machine
shapes for machine shapes but I just
want to call that there was a session
two days ago that goes much more deeply
into detail and all of these sessions
will be posted on to YouTube so check
this out of is interesting to you
another tool that we offer here at
Google cloud is the idea of custom
machine types so the general purpose
line of VMs that I just talked about
they do come with some cookie cutter
configurations but at the same time you
actually have the flexibility to change
the shape of the machine and in
increments of two VP CPUs or increments
of 1 gigabytes of memory and we find
that especially as customers start to
around the corner of cloud adoption and
become more mature in their deployments
that they can get a lot of bang for
their buck by right sizing their
machines using custom machine types so
for example if you if you start with a
cookie cutter of configuration but then
you realize that your underutilizing
your memory you can just scale back the
memory for that instance you shutdown
the instance scale back to memory and
then turn it back on again and you'll
see that the memory is gone down so it's
really easy to do this if you go into
the UI you'll just see a set of sliders
here or in g-cloud you can use the
custom CPU a custom memory flag another
use case we hear from customers a lot is
they might have fault tolerant jobs or
short-lived tasks that they need to do
maybe they don't really care when these
tasks happen or and maybe these tasks
are kind of embarrassingly parallel
right it's a little bit of computation
that you can that you can spin up finish
and then go go on examples of this
include rendering or genomics or media
transcoding and for those use cases we
have the preemptable machine VMs so pre
n 12 Ian's they have they're offered in
the same machine types and machine
shapes that I just talked about they'll
last for up to 24 hours but they can be
preempted without the within that 24
hour time period with
30-second notification the trade-off
being that they're up to 80% cheaper
than regular instances and so we hear a
lot of customers when they start their
cloud journey they'll make everything a
regular or non-preemptive VM
but as they deploy they start to
identify certain workloads that fit this
criteria and then they can migrate those
jobs to be preemptable instead and doing
so save a lot of money right and so you
can see with its you can think of it as
a setting on a VM when you create it and
so you can you can just set the
preemptable flag there and you're off to
the races with a pre-emptive VM okay as
we've kind of matured with our customers
another thing we started to hear is that
some customers are really sensitive to
what they call single host tenancy so
they say I'm happy moving to the cloud
but the host machines that hosts my VMs
I don't want them hosting VMs from other
customers now this might be because they
have regulatory or compliance
requirements that involve evolved in an
on-premises world which meant that so
that's how they've always this is how
they've always operated and they don't
want to go and change those compliance
requirements or this might be because of
Licensing limitations for those use
cases we've recently g8 what we call
sole tenant nodes so this is the ability
to take a physical server and reserve it
just for your use cases and just for
your VMs so what does that look like so
on the left here we see a normal house
so this is a normal this is a non sole
tenant node this is what you've always
been using on GCE we manage the host
Hardware in both cases but in this
particular case other customers may have
VMs that are also running in the same
host Hardware we of course manage the
isolation for you and and all that but
if you have certain requirements that I
just talked about you can move on to a
sole tenant host so there what's
happening is you now have this machine
reserved exclusively for your VMs but
you should note that you still have the
flexibility within that machine to set
up VMs of different shapes and sizes and
to change the configurations of sizes as
needed so this is a bit of a newer
feature we're just trying to see some
adoption there but I want to walk
through what that looks like so you can
get a sense of how easy this is to
actually go ahead and deploy so we're
inside the the developer console the UI
this is
all these features that I'm going to
talk about are accessible from the UI
and the g-cloud and the API surface but
I think that UI just makes it a little
clearer sometimes so walk through here
we are in the UI we're in the compute
engine section we click on sole tenant
nodes you can see I'm asked to just
create one in creating one I'm just
asked for a few configuration settings
like what do you want to call it and how
big do you want the machine to be it's
just a few step process and once I've
created it you'll see an entry here kind
of hard to see but that basically that
line entry there represents a single
sole tenant host ready to host your VMs
and here you can see this particular
configuration or maybe you can't see it
but it has 96 V CPUs and SiC over 600
gigabytes of RAM and you can fit as many
VMs in there as you want all that fit
within that configuration from there
when you create a VM you can just
specify this the sole tenant node group
that you want the VM to fit into and
everything else is the same so it's the
same you know every other part of
managing that VM is the same as before
same as you're used to as long as you
specify that particular node group which
you can see in the g-cloud command over
there you'll find that the VM is now
going to be hosted and dedicated
hardware so one thing that we think this
will really help on is it'll allow you
to bring your existing licenses to GCP
so as we've been working with customers
enterprise-grade customers we found that
many of them have for example Microsoft
software licenses already purchased
Microsoft Windows licenses already
purchased and that the cost for them on
GCE up until now sometimes the cost for
the licensing was actually overshadowing
the costs of the V CPU and RAM for these
customers and so one of our biggest
goals in the past year was to allow you
to take these licenses that you had
already purchased from Microsoft or from
other software vendors and apply them to
GCP so that you don't have to rebuy them
when you're on GCP and so next we
announced the ability to bring your own
license this is in beta and the way that
this works is you can set up a sole
tenant node and in doing so you'll be
compliant with the microsoft bring your
own license requirements for dedicated
hardware and perc or licensing
and in doing so you can then apply the
licenses you've already purchased to to
your GC deployment so you have some
options here I want to walk through some
of them the option one so this option
actually already existed even before we
did this work but in talking with
customers we found that very few
customers actually realized this was an
option so I just want to reiterate it
here so in this option you don't use all
Tennant nodes you just use our typical
multi-tenant hardware and it turns out
for if you have Software Assurance with
Microsoft you can use the license
mobility program to bring software
licenses into GCP already for example
for sequel server so in this
configuration you're still paying for
the premium Windows images and GCP but
you can at least bring your software
licenses too to your GCP hardware option
- this is the one we're announcing here
is you would use the sole tenant nodes
that we just talked about those so
tenant nodes are compliant with the
Microsoft bring your own license
requirements such that they allow you to
bring both your Windows licenses and
your Microsoft software licenses onto
GCP and you don't need the Software
Assurance you don't need to have
Software Assurance for Microsoft in
order to do so so we're already seeing
some customers move on to this
particular model and it really allows
them to get the mileage from their
existing software licenses and apply
that to apply that to GCB ok so the next
section I want to talk about is around
managing your data so before we were
talking about virtual machines now I
want to talk about the discs and the
images and the snapshots that you have
in compute engine and the tools that we
offer you to manage them and to give you
some guardrails behind them the first
thing and this is something we've been
hearing increasingly from customers
especially those in regulated industries
is they might have some compliance or
regulatory requirements around I need to
control how my data is encrypted and how
my data is managed in compute engine I
need to make sure that for example if if
I had to I can totally revoke access for
that data from everybody including the
cloud provider including Google right
and so a practice that's increasingly
being adopted we're seeing is the use of
so what happens is the customers can
create keys and
cloud key management service so that's a
managed service that we offer for key
management and key storage and what you
can do is you go go ahead and create a
key in Cod kms you point GCE to it and
then GCE will automatically start
encrypting your keys
sorry encrypting your disks and images
and snapshots with those keys and at any
moment you can actually revoke access of
those keys from GCE
and what that means is GC will stop
having access to the data so let's walk
through that a little bit just in a bit
more concrete details so you would first
start by creating a key ring and a key
in Cod kms that's a very quick process
you would specify for example the
rotation period and the name of the key
and where it lives and then from there
when in GCE you go to actually create a
disk or image or snapshot you'll find an
option to point GCE to the key that you
just created here in the UI you can see
it's a it's one of a few options and you
have g-cloud as well you have the KMS
key flag where you can specify the URI
for the key and that's and that's
basically it
once you've done that you've set up
you've told you to e to protect your
disks and images and snapshots with that
particular key and from there you can
revoke access as needed you can do that
in the UI by just clicking on the
disable option there or there's a
disabled command in G cloud and from
there you'll find that compute engine
now no longer has access to that data
and so for example if you took that disk
and you tried mounting it to a VM or if
the Bick was the disk receives me the
disk is already mounted onto the VM and
you started it you would find that those
actions would fail until the VM until
there the key was restored another thing
we've heard from customers especially
those in other regions is they want the
ability to store all data in a
particular location so for example we
have a lot of customers in Europe and
what they tell us is I need to make sure
that no none of my data lives in
anywhere else other than the European
Union and so up until this point you
know disks persistent disks have always
been regional or zonal resources and so
that meant you did you have control over
exactly where those disks live up until
this point though images and snapshots
so images are used to create disks
snapshots are used to back up disk state
they have been global resources and so
that's been convenient for say a global
software deployment where you can have a
global deployment and a single image
resource that's global and it's you know
supporting that entire deployment or
backups that support a global deployment
but customers have been asking us for a
lot more flexibility in being able to
say I want this particular image or
snapshot to live in a particular region
or location and only live in that
location and so we're announcing here
the ability to do to specify storage
locations for both images and snapshots
now for snapshots it turns out that's
already been released to beta we did
that in the lead up to next but we're
also going to for sure be doing that for
images as well that's coming soon to
alpha so the way this works it's very
simple there should be the minimal
influence to your to any of your
workflows but if you go into so we're
back in the compute engine UI this is
the list of snapshots we'll do this for
the list of images as well we'll just
tell you for each snapshot now where the
actual storage location of the data is
and similarly when you're creating that
image or when you're creating that
snapshot you'll have an option now to
say this is where I want that image or
snapshot to live if you don't specify
that option it'll continue to be
multi-regional the way it always was you
can see the Associated g-cloud command
there it's fairly easy but much more
flexibility another thing we saw
customers do is they're using snapshots
to make sure they have backups of the
state of their VMs and what we saw a lot
was a pattern of customers writing their
own automation writing their own tooling
to make sure that these snapshots were
generated in on a regular basis so every
day or every week or every month and we
saw so much of this and so much of these
custom tools that we thought hey you
know what we should actually offer an
easy way for you to do this that's
Google managed and that reduces the
maintenance overhead on your on your
side and so leading up to next we
introduced what we call scheduled
snapshots to beta so this is a publicly
available feature now we highly
encourage you to go play with it and
what this will do is it allows you to
tell us the platform to automatically
take snapshots for you
on a regular basis so here's what that
looks like so now if you go into the
snapshots view you'll see a new tab here
called snapshot schedules so this is
where you can create and modify
schedules if I were to go and create a
schedule I could specify a bunch of
things for example when do I want this
schedule to execute how long do I want
these snapshots to stick around for what
should I do if the disc is deleted
things of that sort so here in
particular I'm creating a snapshot
schedule that's set to run daily and to
take snapshots at around noon once I
have that scheduled I can then click
into a disc so here I am in the list of
discs I can click into that and then
apply the snapshot schedule to the disc
so here I am a plot I'm inside the edit
disc page here and I apply the snapshot
schedule that I just created easy as
that and from here you'll see that
compute engine is going to automatically
start applying those that schedule for
you these snapshot schedules they don't
charge there's no charge associated to
creating these schedules you're just
gonna be paying for the storage of the
snapshots as you always have and the
other nice thing about this is snapshots
are differential in nature which means
when you take a snapshot it's only
storing the differential between the
current time and the previous snapshot
what that means is if your disc is not
changing very much in between the
snapshots you won't be charged very much
and in particular if this doesn't change
at all you won't be charged at all so
another powerful tool we just rolled
this out we're already seeing some some
great adoption from some of our early
adopters and they've said that it's
being able to allow them to basically
throw away all of the custom tooling and
scripts that they built around this okay
so from NetFlow so that was a recap of
some of the new features and a few of
the best practices around GCE but a
common question we get asked kind of
around this point as we start to talk
about best practices is how do I make
sure that the people in my organization
that developers my organization are
actually following these best practices
how do I monitor what's going on in my
organization and then how do I start to
enforce some certain set of best
practices or policies and start to put
up those guardrails so that I can make
sure that people are doing the right
thing and
motivate this I want to talk about
sprawl for a second so this here is a
picture of urban sprawl this is San
Francisco looking out over the horizon
and you can see there's you know
buildings buildings and buildings
everywhere
similarly when we've been working with
some of our enterprise customers what we
see is the concept of cloud sprawl so
you open up GCP to your developers and
almost overnight what what we've seen is
you have hundreds or thousands of
projects spring up because every
developer gets their hands on it they do
some code labs or tutorials every time
they do that a new project spins up all
of a sudden you have thousands of
projects and in that environment it can
be very difficult to get your head or
wrap your head around what there is in
your organization and also to make sure
that people are following the best
practices right it can just devolve into
into a bit of a mess and so that's what
this section is all about is how do you
make sense of that mess how do you start
to govern that mess part of the mess is
good because it's agility and as people
moving quickly but you want to make sure
that again they're not falling off a
cliff in doing so so the first thing I
want to talk about a little bit is the
resource hierarchy so what we found
working with customers is that building
a proper resource hierarchy is a really
really great force multiplier for you to
help you understand what all is going on
in your organization so this is a 300
level talk so I'm not going to dwell too
much on this particular diagram although
I hope you've seen it before but in
general I just want to reiterate that in
Google Cloud you have resources like VMs
and dix disks and subnets those are all
up into projects so every resource must
have a project and then projects roll up
optionally into folders and then folders
roll up into organizations and what
happens here is when you set a policy on
a particular say folder it'll roll down
into the projects and then from there
it'll roll down into resources and what
that lets you do is it lets you start
grouping resources that you want to have
similar policies on together so that you
don't have to reason over those
resources individually right and once
you have that resource hierarchy it
allows you to just have a lot more human
comprehensibility around your decisions
so that was super abstract and recently
I was talking to a customer and this is
one of our biggest customers and and the
person said
well you know we heard that feel like a
hundred times even still after two years
of deploying Google cloud we still don't
really have a resource hierarchy we just
have thousands of projects all reporting
up into a single organization and when I
asked that individual why they said well
you know we know what a folder is we
knew what a project is we'd never really
just had an understanding of how to put
it all together or any case studies or
anything like that so I'm glad to report
that that particular individual has now
actually you know that organization has
gone on and built a very effective
resource hierarchy but in case any of
you are in that same boat I wanted to
share a much more concrete example and
this is how Google com this is how our
Google internally has structured our
resource hierarchy so Google we it turns
out we have over four-and-a-half million
projects reporting up into Google com
and you can imagine in that situation
how much of a mess it might be if you
had to reason over all of those projects
individually and so we've done some
things with our folder hierarchy to try
to make sense of that so the first thing
we have is the concept of what we called
the Google default folder so this is a
folder that encapsulates all of the
sandbox projects that our developers end
up creating and what that means is we
can start reasoning over those sandbox
projects together rather than one by one
and so we limit the our end users to
only be able to create projects
willy-nilly in this particular folder
that means we know this folder has all
the sandbox projects and in an intern we
can then apply the policies that make
sense on these sandbox projects for
example we can apply a policy that says
well you know what sandbox projects
probably shouldn't have external IP
addresses they probably shouldn't be
accessible from the public internet or
something like sandbox projects they
probably shouldn't have VMs that are too
large or that are running overnight or
you know off business hours because
maybe there's not a much use case for
that right so continuing along those
lines we have another set of like
policies which is for demo projects so
in this particular case we have a bunch
of demos maybe they're being built by
the sales team with the developer
relations team we group them onto a
folder some demo some policies will
apply for all demos for example it's
probably okay for a demo to be to have
an external IP address in some cases
it's probably okay for you to share
demos
with external audiences in some cases
what we found is that there are also
some differences between how different
teams want to handle their demos and so
we split demos into so we split into
some subfolders below one for the sales
team and one for the developer relations
team so that we can delegate some
additional access to those teams and say
you get to manage your policies within
this folder
another thing we noticed is that the dev
and test environments for our different
engineering teams all tend to sort of
look the same and so we have a team's
folder there we apply some general
policies for what Devon tests should
look like but then we also have
individual team folders that our
individual teams can manage and then we
delegate access to another thing that we
found at Google is that we do have some
subsidiaries some acquisitions we do
want to group them under the top-level
org because we want to keep tabs on them
and because we want to still be able to
reason over all the resources in our
organization but then we break them off
into subfolders like verily in Google X
and then give broad delegation
administrative powers to those
particular subsidiaries and this is a
pattern that we see happen a lot for
other companies as well when they do
with acquisitions and then finally we
have the production folder so the
production folder we found just like
with Devon test production tends to have
a similar set of policies applied to
them so we apply those policies to the
production the top level production
folder where they go down into all of
the folders subfolders and sub resources
but then we do have individual services
as well in there so these are the and
then we allow the individual teams
access to those folders and we allowed
them to set their own policies there as
well so this is a simplified version of
a resource hierarchy that we use at
Google it's also by far not the only way
to do it for sure but I hope this gives
you an example of how you can take four
and a half million projects and start
grouping them into folders in a way that
allows you to reason over them more
easily and allowing you to set policies
over them more easily okay so once you
have a resource hierarchy another
question that comes is how do i how do I
more easily see all that's going on
my organization even and this is a
problem regardless of you know how
well-structured your research hierarchy
is although the hierarchy does help and
so I want to talk about the tools that
we offer you to help monitor your
enterprise to help see what's going on
inside that sprawl and what's who's
creating virtual machines who's creating
data and things of that sort so there's
two tools I want to talk about and we're
going to build them up into some use
cases as we go along
the first one is audit logs so audit
logs are gonna give you a real-time view
of the individual events that are going
on in your organization there are three
types and you can think of these three
types as combining together to create to
give you that view the first type is
admin activity these are gonna log the
administrative actions that users are
taking like creation and deletion and
modification of resources the second
type is the system event these are going
to log the events that GCE is taking on
your behalf to maintain your VMs so for
example instance zero one was live
migrated at 1:00 p.m. and the third type
is data access this tracks not
modifications but just reads of
resources so for example Alice at 1:00
p.m. listed all the images in her
project all of these logs are created in
real time with sub-second latencies and
that opens up some really interesting
possibilities as you start to ingest
these logs that we'll talk about in a
second they're also immutable so users
can't go in and actually change the logs
after they were created admin activity
logs and system that logs will last for
over a year are by default retained over
a year and data access logs for 30 days
and all of these laws can be exported to
cloud storage bigquery or pub/sub so
once you do that especially when you
export to cloud storage or bigquery now
obviously the retention policies don't
apply to them anymore you can retain
them as long as you want and for pup's
of this this opens up the door to some
actions that you can take immediately
once audit logs are generated admin
activity logs and system event logs are
generated by default so they're on by
default for all projects whenever your
user creates a project you'll those
audit logs will start flowing and
finally admin activity logs and system
event logs are not charged at all
whereas data access logs they are
charged by
Ingres volume so data access logs in
general the best practice here is if you
know you need it we suggest you turn
them on there's even a way to blacklist
certain users so that they don't
generate data access logs but you should
be cautious of the ingress volume
charges to make this a little bit more
concrete we can take a look at what an
audit log actually looks like so we
provide a number of ways for you to go
in and actually view your your audit
logs Here I am in the developer console
I can go into the logging section here
and I'll just see a list of all the
audit logs and then I can filter down
that list as needed and if you look into
a particular audit log you'll find that
we provide a really rich set of
information for each so here's a
particular admin activity log for a user
that stopped the GC instance and you'll
see the email address of the user what
they did what resource they acted on and
if they had any other for example fields
in the request body you would see all of
that as well and so you really get a lot
of visibility into what users are doing
in your organization and so a scenario
or a question that tends to come up is
okay well I have 4,000 projects they're
all generating audit logs do I have to
go into each project to chase that
project down and make sure it's
exporting somewhere or in other words
how can I have all these auto logs going
to a single place so that no matter how
many projects I have in my organization
no matter how many folders I have I can
make sure that I still have visibility
over all of that and so a best practice
here is we have a feature called
aggregated logs export that lets you do
that and so when emanated logs export
you can specify at an organization or a
folder level that all of the projects
beneath that organization or folder are
sending your audit logs to a single
centralized place so here's the g-cloud
command to do that so what we're saying
is g-cloud logging syncs create so we're
creating a new export we're exporting
particular to a particular bucket which
is above this line this line says we
want to export for this particular
organization we're saying we want to
filter down to just the admin activity
logs
maybe that's what we're interested in
this particular example and then we're
saying this is the most important flag
here the include children flag says
apply this to not only this organization
but actually to all of the projects and
folders and resources underneath that
organization and so with this one
we're able to answer that previous
question and we're able to make sure
that we have a single GCS bucket with
all of the events that are happening in
my entire organization and this is
getting updated in real time a
real-world example of what we've seen
folks do with audit logs is well here's
a real world example so we have
companies that are really interested in
reacting to insider risks and sometimes
we might have it inside our risks
morning around a user that's doing you
know who may have had their credentials
compromised who may be doing some
unwanted things inside the organization
and so with audit logs and with the
search functionality in audit logs you
can use that to easily filter down the
audit logs to just the actions that a
particular user took so in this
particular example what we're doing is
for this g-cloud command for example we
can say I want to read the audit logs
that just go against GCE instances that
are just about admin activity and that
just involved this particular Alice user
that I'm interested in you can also zoom
in for example on a particular instance
to see the history of that instance now
in this particular example we're just
looking at a particular project but you
can imagine how you can combine this
particular use case with the previous
one where you're aggregating all the
logs across your organization to have an
easily search to easily search against
all the activities are happening in here
in your organization and we find that to
be a really powerful tool now we
released audit logs a long time ago and
we've seen a lot of adoption but
sometimes we get the question of you
know I don't care so much about the view
of all the events in the world as I care
about the state of all of my resources
at a given point in time and this is
sort of possible to reconstruct using
audit logs but it takes a little bit of
work and it's just not a you know an
easy streamlined good thing to do and so
as a result we've introduced and we've
g8 very recently the cloud asset
inventory API so this is a powerful API
that will for any given state in time in
the past five weeks it'll allow you to
export what all of your resources look
like and what all the policies on those
resources look like and so what does
that look like so these are API so we'll
be making an API request
appear in the first line you can see
we're requesting the access token that's
just the canonical way to get the access
token and then we attach it onto the
request here and then what we can do is
we're calling the cloud as an inventory
API is on a particular project and we're
saying export assets for that for that
project you can also call them on a
folder or on an organization and it'll
do the same thing in this particular
case we're asking for a resource as
opposed to resources and the policies so
we're saying get all the resources for
this project and then we're saying dump
that all into a GCS bucket so once
you've done that you'll see just a just
a list of all of the resources in that
project now we didn't say what time to
do it so the cloud asset inventory is
assumed to do it for you know right now
but you could also specify a time
anytime in the past five weeks this is
what the response looks like so in blue
you'll see some metadata about this
entry so this is basically uh saying we
found an instance it's parented to this
project this is the information about it
and then in green you can see we printed
out all the properties of that
particular resource so you'll see what
the CPU platform is the disattached to
it basically every property that you
would see from you know making a get
request against that resource so these
API is this API has just been G aid
we've just started to work with
customers on this we found but we've
already found that customers are using
these api's to implement a pretty
powerful and wide range of use cases so
for example you can as kind of the first
thing to do you can just see how many
projects have GCE resources inside of
them working with one customer they we
know we asked him upfront before they
did this experiment how many they
thought there were and they said around
100 it turns out they had over 500
resources 500 projects excuse me with GC
resources so they were really glad today
that they made this request and it's
just another example of the sprawl that
happens inside organizations that are
rolling out the cloud you can also do
things like how many VMs have external
IP addresses or how is my persistent
disk versus local SSD mix changing over
time that's a cost optimization one or
because this API also tells you about
the policies that are applied
you can also say hey at a particular
moment in time who had access to a
particular set of resources for example
if you are on investigating a security
incident or something like that
and so you can imagine you know with
these API is with these API s and with
just a little bit of iteration over the
results you can really do some powerful
scanning the last section we have here
is around enacting and enforcing
policies and so this is all around you
know now that I know the state of the
world and now that I have the resource
hierarchy to reason over that in a more
human comprehensible sort of way how can
I start to put up some guardrails how
can I start to start enforcing that some
of the best practices that we just
talked about actually be implemented by
my organization at large and so when I
say the word policies I mean that in the
broadest sense of the term for a city a
policy might be you know all buildings
need to have two fire escapes or
buildings in this region can only be
under 20 stories for cloud in the cloud
world a policy might be for security
purposes right you might say hey
resources shouldn't be shared outside of
the organization or this is a set of
people who can do X on this set of
resources they can also be for
compliance reasons we use the example
before the organization in the European
Union they want to have a policy that
says my users shouldn't be able to stand
up resources in outside of the of the EU
or they can be for cost savings right
you can say something like hey VMs in a
sandbox project they should be shut down
on weekends and holidays
you should have VMs underneath a certain
size etc etc and there's a number of
other reasons too now when we talk about
enacting and enforcing policies I want
to draw a dichotomy here you can enforce
policies before the fact which is to say
you can place limits on activities
before they happen I might say users are
not able to create a disk in a
particular region and if they try to
they'll get an error or we can enact
policies after the fact as well so we
can maybe be a little more permissive
for users and allowed them to take a
certain action but once they take an
action we're constantly scanning the
environment to see whether or not the
action happened
to see what things are happening and
taking action against violations of
policies so at this point you might ask
well why not only do things before the
fact right why am I even allowing taking
the risk of allowing some actions to
happen and then reacting to it well so
for some policies for like life-or-death
policies or you know security policies
you should certainly enforce them before
the fact that's for sure but if you're
just enforcing them before the fact how
do you know that you're doing that in
the right way right and so one reason to
enforce both before and after the fact
is defense-in-depth let's say I don't
want to have external any VMS in my
organization with external IP addresses
because I'm very worried about data
exfiltration what I can do is I
certainly won't allow my users to create
VMs with external IDs but then I also
scan after the fact to see what are all
my VMs and do any have external IPs and
so I can be doubly confident that I
truly am following and abiding by the
policy another reason to enforce after
the fact is for things where they're
more of a best practice or a more want
to nudge my users towards that behavior
and in that case you'll find that you by
enforcing after the fact which I'll give
some examples on in a second
you can be a lot more expressive and do
a lot more actions as opposed to being
enforcing before the fact okay but first
we'll zoom in on enforcement before the
fact what one part we have a number of
tools to set policies that I'll you know
prevent behavior before it happens of
course one is the iam policy so this is
using the built-in Identity and Access
Management tools you can extend policies
on resources to say who can do what on
them so for example I can apply a policy
that says this particular set of users
they have this set of permissions on
this set of organize organize a ssin so
on and so forth we also have the concept
of an organizational policy so whereas I
am policies are in the business of
granting permissions to particular sets
of users when you set up an organization
policy these are in the business of
placing restrictions on resources so I
can set up a organizational policy for
example that says I don't want any
external IP addresses we're also working
on another one calling back to the
previous example which says I don't want
to have any resources store
in a particular location or region and
finally another tool that we're seeing
becoming a lot more prevalent among
larger organizations is for enforcement
before the fact is the concept of having
a level of automation sitting between
the users and the GCE so this is an
actual real-life case study from one of
our customers what they do is they don't
allow any of their end users to create
projects instead these users go to a
ServiceNow portal that they've
implemented they go in the ServiceNow
portal and they request a project we
created that ask some questions to the
user about what they want the project to
be used for and in turn might even kick
off some approval workflows but after
that once assuming that it's approved
what this ServiceNow does is it calls up
a Jenkins job which will automatically
create a project on behalf of the user
and when it creates the project it is
able to create the project with some
specific set of defaults that are kind
of more trusted and more safe so for
example what they do is they delete the
default Network because by default will
create a new network with every single
project and instead they'll hook up the
project to a shared network that they've
created which is more centrally
administered and also in doing so they
can set up some other good defaults on
the project like the I am roles and
things like that and so in doing so I
think they've come to a good mix of
agility with the right guardrails so
their developers can still move quickly
they can still create projects as needed
but now they have the right guardrails
on that project to make sure the
developers don't veer off a cliff so
this is all I'll say on the subject for
now but I do want to cut we did have a
session that goes much much deeper into
all of these topics yesterday called
best practices for privacy and security
and compute engine if this subject
matter interests you I would highly
suggest you take that you check that out
you can also do enforcement after the
fact and this is where some of the
really interesting pieces come together
so one best practice we're seeing in the
field is the ability to take automated
actions from audit logs so as I
mentioned before you can actually export
an audit log to pub/sub and
that means is as those actions happen in
real time you'll get a push to pub/sub
that you can then subscribe to and then
you can take actions on so at the start
of the talk I talked about scheduled
snapshots and the ability to set up
those schedules let's say you wanted to
enforce that as a best practice in your
organization you want to say any time a
disc is created I want to encourage my
users or I want to create a scheduled
snapshot for those users so what you
could do for example is you could take
your logs and export them to cloud
pub/sub and you might constrain or
filter your logs to just the ones that
are that are disc creation events or VM
creation events that have disk
creationists associated with them so now
you have a club pub subtopic that has
basically a constant stream of every
disk that's being created in your
organization and from there you can set
up cloud functions or any other you know
kind of managed service or it could even
be a VM that just listens to these pups
up to this pub subtopic that you set up
so basically it gets triggered every
time a disc gets created in your
organization and what they can do is
they can read that audit log it can
understand whether or not this disk has
a scheduled snapshot attached to it and
if not it can take action so it might
for example email the creator and say
hey I noticed you didn't have a
scheduled snapshot
you should probably attach one or it
could go further and just automatically
create a snapshot for you right and so
in this case you're starting to guide
your organization towards a set of best
practices and you also see how this
approach has a lot more flexibility
right it takes a little bit more work
but has a lot more flexibility and you
know kind of how heavy-handed you want
it to be with your guardrails you can
also imagine if you have an aggregated
log export you can make this even easier
right you can scale this across your
entire organization because now you can
you know deploy this once and it applies
to all the logs that are being generated
across your organization another best
practice we're seeing and this is around
is around automated scanning of your
environments and using the information
from the automated scan to check for
pilot policy violations so in the
example here let's say we want to ensure
that no discs exist outside of the e
European Union
then what I can do is I can use a cloud
asset inventory to export all of the
disks in my organization to GCS once I
have that list it's a pretty simple job
to just iterate over that file detect
the region for each disk and if there is
a disk outside of the European Union I
can take the appropriate action maybe
that means I file a ticket or I got eye
contact the person who owns it or a more
extreme version you know I can just go
and delete that disk and then you can
wait some interval and repeat step one
so you're constantly you can constantly
be scanning your environment and in
doing so you can it's also a great
vehicle to start enforcing some of these
policies right so with that that brings
us to the end of this talk hopefully
this has been helpful in showing you
some of the best practices and the tools
that we have for enterprise deployments
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]